It's great to welcome back to the program Michael Wood Jr.
Who's a police management expert, activist, president of Veterans Stand as well as former Baltimore police commander
Michael, it's great to have you back on the program and the timing really couldn't be better although
I don't know if 'better' is the right word to use here
You reacted to the speech that Donald Trump gave in front of a law-enforcement crowd
where he sort of jokingly said, you know it's really not a bad idea to kind of rough up suspects that you have in custody
if they've been accused or are suspected of having committed a serious enough crime
Which to me- it was disturbing on so many levels
Not the least of which that being arrested for something is not the same as having been convicted
Of something regardless of how serious it is. So take it from the top
I mean, what was your reaction to the comments from President Trump?
Well, thanks for having me again, and I mean the basic
Idea that's really bothering me when it comes to what Trump is saying is that
That's the seed that we kind of have in our culture that we aren't looking at the command structure
We aren't looking at the actual power that's setup incentivizing all this and setting these balls in motion. What we end up doing is we
Blame the officer that actually bangs the head on the door
But this whole thing is a part of a culture
That comes down and when you are the president then you are talking down to police officers
or whoever's out on the street to execute your will, to go and do something that is against the basic premise of
professional law enforcement even if- even as bad American law enforcement is
there is not a best practices book or police expert out there that's going to say you treat
Convicted suspects this way let alone
Citizens who are proven innocent or innocent until proven guilty so there- there is this systemic
attitude where policing ends up
Encapsulating like what America really is and
I'm anti Trump just as much as I'm anti sneezing
But I don't blame the sneeze for my sneeze, like he is a product of us and if we can't see that that this
really demonstrates
What America is in its soul and we need to fight that
Then I don't really know what people are looking at
There's a similar idea that we sometimes hear when it comes to the
sentencing of individuals convicted of child sex abuse and some other crimes sometimes- this idea that
Hey, their punishment will be made worse because they might get sexually assaulted
in our prisons or in our jails. And when I hear that I say
That's not something that we should be applauding because it's going to make their time worse
That's sort of an inability of our
prison system to keep individuals
safe like the fact that you might be sexually assaulted in prison depending on the crime that you're convicted of
That's something that we should be concerned about not cheering as part of some additional justice
Is there similarity between these two ideas?
We should be incredibly concerned
And I'm really happy you brought that up and have made that connection that you see in our prison system and again that is
America right we say to ourselves. Let's punish this person. Let's put them into a system
Where, they will have injustice inhumanity
They will they will be assaulted and have all this punishment
Go down upon them despite the fact that punishment isn't going to do anything to make the situation better
And then we are trying to like change the prison system and say criminal justice needs to be better
but at the same time
Applauding when someone we don't like goes into an inhumane system. We do the same thing with police like
as much as I want to see accountability in policing
There is no justice in sending a police officer to an inhumane and injust system
So we have to really look in ourselves
To figure out like what do we really want Policing to be?
Are we the country that's going to stand up and say we want to be a punitive thing
We don't care about science despite the fact that every
Meta-analysis of scientific Literature will show you that punishment does not equal a deterrent. That we are still so hell-bent on being a violent society
That wants to even think that these things would work
Like we're going down a pathway that is incredibly concerning to me and obviously it is to you
You used the word 'systemic'
a little bit earlier in the interview, and I think if we sort of imagine a spectrum
You might have those completely on one side who believe that the issues with police violence and police brutality are 100% systemic
and that there's very little blame to place on the individual officers. On the other side of that spectrum you might imagine those who
believe this is merely a few bad apples, only the individual police officers are to blame here
and there is nothing systemic going on. The truth is probably sort of somewhere in the middle of that
But I want to ask you, where do you think it is? In other words,
How much of this problem is the individuals? How much of the problem is systemic?
I'm- Well of course I'm throwing out bullshit park number, but I'm going to go with probably 95%
To 99% is completely systemic.  The way I can kind of encapsulate this on
An individual intimate level here is that I grew up
Trying to be raised 'blind'. I mean I grew up in the age of information in mixed neighborhoods
And I had this idea to myself that as a police officer what I was going to do is be impartial
I was going to follow the letter of the law, I was going to follow the departmental policies to a tee and it
Took me a while, but I realized eventually at the end that all of my actions of what I was
empirically doing on the street was was racist it was
Prejudice against the society, it was inhumane. It was it was in just and all of those things that I was doing?
I was really looking at the system and saying if we do this perfectly, if we do this system perfectly then we will have justice-
So explain that a little bit like so for example
I mean having interviewed you before ,would one example of what you're talking about be
Despite the reality that you went in
Wanting to be race blind and not discriminating etc for example by virtue of the neighborhoods you were
policing, the impact of your policing was going to be effectively racist? Is that an example of what you mean?
Yeah, that's a good example
Or whether I put someone into bonds or whether I was looking at so I thought I was a narcotics detective, hunting down
narcotics, but I wasn't. There was an entire half of that city
Which we know empirically, without a doubt and anyone can argue it and I know it from practical experience
That white communities have just as much drugs if not more- one reason why cocaine sentencing is much higher is not because of a racist
Thing intentionally, it's because cocaine is a white drug and so white drugs end up having more resources
so a mid-level dealer ends up being much higher on the scale of being a
'Resource'- same damn word I used a second ago- but so those things that we really end up doing
We think this is normal
But when we end up going after the drug deal- Where do they put me? They put me in East and West Baltimore
to go after drug dealers
So I end up going after only the community because the drug dealing and drug possession is actually equal if not
More in a rich and white community. Think about it, drugs are expensive
Like they're- I mean people with money have more drugs than people without money that is even is even rational
But where was I sent to go get the drugs? In redlined
Poor neighborhoods to put into an inhumane system that how's about
System that they can't
Can't do so it's not like- it's not necessarily the officers thought that when they're doing that
and even if they do it well, they send people into
a system
So even if you had a police department
That was operating perfectly, they would still be sending people and handing them off to a state's attorney who-
States attorneys are blatantly corrupt around around the country-
They are incentivized in that same system
So they have the same problems, they're incentivized to WIN, not for justice. So like we talked about federal prosecutors ago
'You better be aware those federal prosecutors. They have a ninety seven percent
Conviction rate' Well, they don't have a ninety seven percent 'conviction' rate they have a 97 percent
'victory' rate which means that cases are pleaded down or
Whatever they do, they use and manipulate power
So that they can rise through the ranks. So they don't get incentivized to do the right thing, they get
Incentivized for the most convictions to rise up through the ranks and then prisons are incentivised to be as efficient as possible.
So give people as really little resources as possible, why we're doing this punishment system. So it is this whole big
institution that police officers are a pawn of. It's the people above the street cops that all set this thing into motion and
Don't take any of the responsibility for it. One reason why you see cops getting away with
committing murders right on camera is
when- that these things Indict the system.
When they indict the system the whole thing will rally around them to protect them and get them off- like Freddie Gray
so when the officers kill Freddie Gray in Baltimore,
no supervisors took accountability for this
So understanding that this killing- What happened was- is- by the court case anyway
He goes into a van, where they're supposed to be transporting him to a prison cell
They already put them in there for really sketchy reasons to begin with
But then they bring them out of the van dead.
So the whole time-
this is a van that doesn't have seatbelts,
doesn't have proper supervision
doesn't have cameras in the back,
doesn't have any accountability
and Freddie Gray was the fourth person to be killed or
Paralyzed in the back of those vans just in recent history
But no command members
Kevin Davis doesn't pay a price,
the Mayor doesn't pay a price
Nobody has anything happened to them other than the individual officer at the bottom who was really just a pawn all along
We've been speaking with Michael. Wood Jr. He is a former Baltimore police commander
You can follow him on Twitter @MichaelAWoodJr and also check out civilianledpolicing.org
Michael, always great to talk to you
Yeah, thanks for having me David. Thanks for throwing in those pitches there
We definitely need people to go to Veterans stand and Civilian led policing
That is the way you guys can take something in your own hand and do something in your community